will you do me the honor
of marrying me
that ladies and gentlemen is my guest
co-host katarina scorsoni turning down
link's proposal just dropping the man
cole that was last season's cliffhanger
finale right um so grey's anatomy does
come back tonight and in its premiere
this is a two-hour crossover with
station 19 which we love we're gonna get
some answers right did you agree with
why she said no during the season they
had many conversations about whether
they would get married or not and she
was very clear that she was not
interested in getting married and he was
respectful of that initially and then
in front of everyone at this wedding on
the beach he proposed with children
involved so i think she was not
appreciating how coercive that situation
was i mean he brought the children
well we recently spoke to your on-screen
baby daddy chris carmack who revealed to
us that he did have a little trepidation
about the proposal let's look at this
yeah i mean you know i'm reading the
script going blink are you sure you want
to do this
uh but you know he swung big he got the
kids in there he got four rings he was
ready and uh yeah no she turned him down
spectacularly
she did she turned him down
spectacularly and i for one am proud
that she held her boundaries yeah four
rings and the baby that man came yeah
that's some pressure that's some
pressure but no means no there you go
well 18 seasons in and people are still
obsessed with this show when do you
think you guys would find out if in fact
this is the final season i literally i
have like i'm ready for a call at any
time we have no idea we're on the edge
of our seats we're kind of waiting to
hear
what the decisions are up top and yeah
okay so go with me here then how would
you like to see amelia's story wrap up
if you had the choice
i mean
she's the queen of the neuro universe
i don't know i i mean i think that i
think she's so passionate about medicine
and so passionate about neurosurgery um
that i would want her to have like a
huge win in that arena well i love that
you play queen mother on screen but
offspring you are also queen mother for
sure you're a mama to the most adorable
little babies yes especially your
four-year-old ah yeah you're almost five
but she's four now yes pippa and pippa
was born with down syndrome and last
year you were honored by it's the global
down syndrome foundation for your
advocacy in the space i think the thing
that i want people to understand down
syndrome is a diversity disability is a
diversity
and
why
see
yay
pippa is smart and i think instead of
looking at it like something that needs
to uh be fixed we need to look at it as
a diversity and something that's
beautiful and different and
all of us share this inherent
human dignity and that is the same but
we all have specific differences that
need to be supported in whatever they
need to be supported so like women we
need feminine products men need razors
and people with down syndrome need
visual learning cues it's not something
that we need to be worried about it's
something that we need to acknowledge
and support appropriately
[Music]
you